[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حتى روسيا لديها الآن نسختها الخاصة من
ماكدونالدز ، فهي تأتي تحت اسم مختلف
هنا يطلق عليها
itachika والتي تعني في الأساس أنها
لذيذة وهذا أيضًا لها علامة
مختلفة أو شعار مختلف يمكنك رؤيته
هناك من المفترض أن يرمز إليه
تقول الشركة إن البطاطس المقلية والهامبرغر
بخلاف ذلك الكثير من الأشياء
تشبه إلى حد كبير ماكدونالدز ، ولكن
لا توجد وجبة كبيرة ولا توجد أيضًا وجبة سعيدة ،
كما ترون أن هذا المكان
مليء بالمربى إلى حد كبير ، فهناك
الكثير حقًا  من الأشخاص الذين أتوا إلى هنا تحدثنا إلى
بعض العملاء ، بما في ذلك بعض الأشخاص الذين كانوا
يرتدون بالفعل رموز
حرب فلاديمير بوتين في أوكرانيا والتي
بالطبع يسميها الروس عملية عسكرية خاصة
، والغذاء والسياسة ليس لديهم أي شيء مشترك
مثل هيا يا رجل ، أبق الأشياء منفصلة في
الأساس  من المهم بالنسبة لي أن
أشعر بشعور ماكدونالدز وأعتقد أنها ليست فكرة جيدة
لأن
ماكدونالدز هو تاريخ إنها علامة تجارية
إنها فكرة رائعة
أنها ليست جيدة  ماكدونالدز lassical
كما ترون النسخة الروسية من
ماكدونالدز
تشبه إلى حد كبير ماكدونالدز ، لديك
برجر بالجبن المضاعف هنا
وهو عبارة عن 9 قطع
وليست ماك ناجتس ، إنه شذرات ونوع
من المشروبات الغازية ، انظر كيف مذاقها ،
لذا فإن العبوة أيضًا رائعة جدًا
على غرار ماكدونالدز ، يمكنك رؤية
الكوب هنا ، كل شيء ما عدا العلامة التجارية
نفسها تنطبق على البطاطس المقلية ، وإذا نظرت
بعناية يمكنك رؤية الصلصات حتى
يبدو أن شعار ماكدونالدز
معتم ، فسترى كيف تبدو الماكناغيتس وكأنها شذرات ،
إنها تمامًا تمامًا  مثل
ماكدونالدز ،
هذا مكان تاريخي للغاية ، وهذا
هو المكان الذي تم فيه افتتاح أول مطعم لماكدونالدز في عام 1990 في ذلك الوقت أثناء
الاتحاد السوفيتي ،
والذي أدى بالطبع
إلى قصة نجاح ضخمة
لماكدونالدز هنا في روسيا
والشركة الروسية التي تم شراؤها الآن  يقول هؤلاء
الامتياز من ماكدونالدز إنهم يأملون في
أن يتمكنوا من تكرار هذا
النجاح فريد بوندكين سي إن إن موسكو